I was going for a while I hurt myself
but now I'm back watch the video I'll
explain yes folks I had a two-month
hiatus there was an accident that
occurred I herniated my disc and
actually lost some motor function in my
legs for a bit I was on a lot of drugs
and have since been rehabbing not not
rehab for the drugs but rehab for the
back eventually I will be making a video
about my rehab and specifically how it
relates to the American healthcare
system but for right now if you want to
follow my rehab step-by-step be sure to
follow me at twitter.com slash s Crowder
but now that I'm back and no longer
soiling myself I will be back to doing
videos regularly last week I am CDC pack
the country's largest political action
conference was a lot of fun always is
and special thanks to Lisa depasquale
for really helping put this on and
always making sure things run smoothly
now there was some controversy
surrounding CPAC this year because of go
proud a gay organization that was one of
the co-sponsors here's how I feel about
that myself personally I am probe
traditional marriage I agree with the
President on this but uh whether you
jujitsu that one ah
but I do want to say listen what do you
agree with the politics of these
particular groups or not I think it's a
great thing to allow people of different
stripes colors and shapes to be included
we're not the party who tells you that
you have to agree with us 100% and
follow lockstep otherwise you don't get
to sit at the cool kids table let's
leave that to the Democrats folks that
being said gayness is still funny and
that's okay it doesn't mean we hate
anybody let's let me tell you too a
straight man why gayness is funny okay
because to a straight man in his mind no
we're in the natural realm of his
reality does it occur to be attracted to
another man it's absurd so it's funny
and let me the same thing if a duck
walked in right now wearing pajamas oh
my god there's a duck in pajamas what
are you doing at CPAC duck in pajamas I
would have never imagined that it's the
same thing when there's a dude like
hello you look delicious oh don't do the
gays won't beat you up I also love how
the mainstream media doesn't know what
to do with conservative gay people does
not compute they're like all you
conservatives hate gays well I'm gay Oh
at Fort rubies you know what to do there
just like ah well how gay are you
I don't know I'm pretty I guess I'm
Anderson Cooper gay
and I'm not quite Clay Aiken flamboyant
but not exactly sexually repressed Rock
Hudson secretly playing doctor with Jim
Nabors gay
of course some folks in the lefty blogs
weren't fans of that material nor this
tidbit we had Rachel Maddow here last
year oh stop it
everyone needs a baritone to bring down
the choir oh come on I like Rachel
Maddow I just don't like getting my news
from someone who sounds like Seth Rogen
yeah I'd read the news this week but I
smoked too much weed while CPAC was fun
it's important for conservatives to
understand that we need to get these
messages out into the real world
see conservatives tend to be far more
engaged and educated in the realm of
politics it's their passion it's their
hobby and so you realize that the
politician sort of become the quasi
celebrities of the conservative movement
the realization was glaringly apparent
when I assured a Haley Barbour off stage
and people were immediately reaching out
for his hand as though he was Jesus I
think I saw some power leaving his robe
conservatives listen most Americans
couldn't even tell you who Mitt Romney
is let alone a lot of these minor
players wish they did but they don't
most of them not even all of them show
up to vote every four years and that's
it but in between those four years they
are all watching movies all watching
television and all listening to music
and that's why I say that the American
culture has vastly more influence than
American politics so especially the
Young Conservatives stop trying to play
junior senator and actor age enough with
the policy wonky lameness bring some
entertainment to your school or
community a comedy show the rock shows
old parties teach a controversial of
immature protests to get some attention
no one else on your campus wants to see
another stiff dry most likely balding
old white guy discuss policy sure they
have important stuff to say but you
won't change any hearts or minds that
way so please ditch the three-piece
suits the bowties words like humorous
and don't be afraid to go shake things
up and for goodness sake do some
push-ups listen the conservative
which is always right but our packaging
often flops do you agree with me
disagree let me know below look at
that's that's teacher arm fat that's
what happens when you herniate a disc
and finally there were some incredible
guests at CPAC this year many of whom
you wouldn't expect please welcome a
special guest mr. Keith Oberman but
that's a video for another week stay
tuned
[Music]